say his name outside court
george floyd's family stood with another
family in grief
you see the baby that they have called
families dear god
another young black man shot by an
officer who fired her handgun
instead of her taser dante wright's
mother was on the phone with him when he
was pulled over
i could hear the police officers and
scruffling with him
she called back and spoke on video to a
passenger
she was crying and screaming and she
said that they shot him
and she pointed the phone towards the
driver's seat and my son was laying
there
unresponsive that was the last time that
i seen my son
that's the last time i heard from my son
and i have had no explanation
since then george floyd's girlfriend
here sobbing with dante's family
told me by a twist of fate she knew him
too
i'm crushed um it's enough that floyd is
gone but for one of my youth to to be
gone as well
i worked with dante for years so he knew
dante yes
yes and he's just a wonderful beautiful
boy
inside court derek shoving's lawyers
began presenting their defense
for the first time the jury heard this
was an appropriate use of force
against george floyd in terms of the
initial uses of force
the officer's efforts to get mr floyd
into the car
you felt that they were objectively
reasonable
i did did the use of force then continue
after uh mr floyd was restrained
on the ground i don't consider a prone
control
as a use of force
the defense showed video evidence of
george floyd being arrested in 2019
a paramedic testifying mr floyd had
taken opioids
the prosecution argued it hadn't killed
him then
he didn't stop breathing no his heart
didn't stop
no you didn't go into cardiac arrest no
he didn't go into a coma
no the trial may conclude as soon as
next week
but for george floyd's brother an all
too familiar story
is playing out in tandem with this trial
felinas when you saw that video of dante
wright
how did you feel i thought after george
floyd
it was slowed down just a little bit but
it looks like a never-ending cycle
and times like this we need to all stand
together with each other
[Music]
the police officer who shot dante wright
has resigned
her 26-year career lasting longer
than his short life sally lockwood sky
news minneapolis